In Texas,
the monarch is close to exhaustion.
With her last reserves,
she's seeking out the perfect spot
to lay her eggs.
Using her amazing sense of smell
she's on the hunt for milkweed,
the only food her babies will eat.
It's a plant
which was once abundant.
But now over three quarters of the state
is farmland,
choked by pesticides and weed killers.
For a butterfly, it's effectively
a desert.
It's not just farms
that have replaced wild landscapes.
Reaching the suburbs of Austin,
she's running on empty.
But incredibly
in flight from over 400 feet away
she's found the needle in the haystack.
This backyard
has exactly what she needs for her eggs.
She lays hundreds on milkweed
specially planted
to help migrating monarchs.
But she'll never meet her babies.
Before they even hatch
she takes her last breath.
Her mission
is complete.
This is the true
miracle of the monarch migration.
It's not a marathon.
It's a relay race.
After about four days,
her caterpillars
hatch in the perfect nursery,
surrounded by food.
And that's all this little bug has on her
mind.
Milkweed is poisonous,
yet she's not only immune.
She's using it for her own defense,
storing the deadly chemicals in her body.
She makes herself
toxic, wearing bright colors
as a warning signal.
In just two weeks,
she'll eat and grow.
And eat.
And grow.
Until she's
3000 times bigger.
Spinning sticky silk to hang from.
She forms a chrysalis.
Over the next ten days,
she breaks herself down
into a kind of genetic soup.
Before putting herself back together,
and emerging
as a butterfly.
She's her mother's daughter, born
born with the same mission
and the same built in G.P.S.